De viszont erre van egy lista, hogy
melyek azok az élelmiszerek, amelyek a
legjobban terítenek, és ezeket az
élelmiszereket ugye általánosságban
azért érdemes beiktatni az az étrendbe,
mert hogyha ezeket rendszeresen
fogyasszuk, akkor ezek hosszú távon
telítettségérzést okoznak, és akkor nem
kelljunk az étkezések között, vagy
kevesebbet tudunk belőle enni. Nézzük
>> és meglepő lesz, meglepő lesz az, amit
fogok mondani, mert a köztudatban ennek
pont az ellentéte van elterjedve. Én
csak az elsőt fogom megemlíteni és a top
kategóriát, mert utána aztán a fehérre
típusok jönnek, de a legelső helyen a
főtt burgonya van. És ugye mindenki
meglepődik ezen, hogy hát az szokott az
első dolog lenni, hogy akkor a
keményítőket, a szénhidrátokat az
étrendből söpördjük kifele. Viszont főtt
burgonyával nagyon jól lehet fogyni. az
egyik leghosszabban és a legjobb
terítettség érzést okozza az emberi
szervezetben. És ahhoz képest kalória
szempontjából meg nagyon kevés.
>> [zene]